hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about how the process of
translation differs in prokaryotes and
eukaryotes make sure you understand that
translation is that final step in gene
expression where you have genetic
information that's stored in DNA and
then it is expressed through a way of an
mRNA intermediate which is used to make
protein in a process of translation so
now let's get started talking about
translation in prokaryotes versus
eukaryotes
prokaryotes we're talking about bacteria
and archaea eukaryotes we're talking
about things like animals and plants and
fungi and algae and so forth
so translation occurs after
transcription in eukaryotes her
transcription is making the RNA using
DNA as a template so making that RNA
intermediate so translation occurs after
transcription in eukaryotes but at the
same time as transcription in
prokaryotes this is referred to as
coupled transcription and translation
where they're occurring simultaneously
the lifespan of the mRNA transcript is
quite short and prokaryotes and much
longer and eukaryotes with prokaryotes
their mRNA usually only lasts a few
seconds or maybe a few minutes whereas
with eukaryotes the mRNA lasted much
longer amount of time we're talking like
hours or even days prokaryotes and
eukaryotes also have different ribosomes
that they use remember that ribosomes
are the cellular machinery where the
mRNA is used as a template to build
proteins prokaryotes use 70s ribosomes
eukaryotes use 80s ribosomes here the s
is a spend burg unit I'll write that
right here fed burg and it's just a
sedimentation
measure so basically eukaryotes have 80s
ribosomes they sediment a little faster
when they're centrifuge procures of
these 70s ribosomes they don't sediment
as quickly there I'm a little bit
lighter essentially I remember that
ribosomes are composed of protein
subunits and also ribosomal RNA and so
not only are these sizes different but
the actual ribosomal proteins and
ribosomal RNA that make up these
ribosomes are different in prokaryotes
versus eukaryotes prokaryotes and
eukaryotes do use the same start codon a
u G but upstream of that start codon
prokaryotes have a special sequence it's
a AGG AGG remember a is adenine G is
guanine and this sequence is called the
shine-dalgarno sequence so named for a
couple of scientists the shine-dalgarno
sequence helps to anchor the 70s
ribosome to the mRNA in prokaryotes this
sequence is absent and eukaryotes so
eukaryotes don't have a shine-dalgarno
sequence but they still have ways to
anchor their 80s ribosomes to their mRNA
and that is through using the five prime
cap and something called a Kozak
sequence the Kozak sequence is not as
rigid as this AGG AGG there's a few
amino acids that have to be the same but
some of the amino acids in and around
those set amino acids are variable and
so I doesn't have like a very defined
sequence the way that the shine-dalgarno
sequence does prokaryotic mRNA also
could have multiple start sites this is
called polycistronic
so polycistronic just means that
multiple genes can be on one mRNA
transcript or the information from
multiple genes and so that encodes
multiple polypeptides or proteins and
polypeptides and proteins are the same
thing so prokaryotic mRNA may have only
one start site and only code for one
protein but it can also have many
whereas eukaryotic mRNA only ever has
one and that is called mono so Stronach
so where one transcript results in one
polypeptide and that's always true for
eukaryotic mRNA prokaryotes and
eukaryotes also have different types and
numbers of elongation and termination
factors so initiation factors are small
proteins that help get translation
started elongation factors are proteins
that make sure that it keeps going and
termination factors are proteins that
help translation and at the appropriate
time and so prokaryotes and eukaryotes
have different types of these factors
and also different numbers of these
factors prokaryotic translation is also
a lot faster prokaryotes can assemble
roughly twenty amino acids per second
remember that amino acids are the
building blocks of proteins eukaryotic
translation on the other hand is quite a
bit slower averaging at only one amino
acid per second and also the initiator
tRNA in proteins carry the initiator
tRNA and prokaryotes carries a different
amino acid or modified amino acid
relative to eukaryotes specifically
eukaryotes the very first tRNA that
comes into the ribosome at the start of
translation to bring what's going to be
the first amino acid
the polypeptide it's always carrying an
amino acid known as Metheny and this is
what methionine looks like
however the initiator tRNA in
prokaryotes is carrying a modified
version of methionine called a formyl
methionine and formyl methionine
basically just has this formal group
that's shown right here that makes it
different from the methionine that's
seen and eukaryotes and that's seen in
other parts of the prokaryotic
polypeptide this formal group Toth is at
the very start of the prokaryotic
polypeptide it does get removed when
translation is over prokaryotes and
eukaryotes also use the same Universal
genetic code what that means is that in
mRNA there are codons which are sets of
three non-overlapping nucleotides that
code for specific amino acids so for
example the start codon Aug always codes
for methionine it's going to be this
kind of methionine and eukaryotes and
this kind of methionine and prokaryotes
that are always close from a tiny and
then there's other sets of triplets of
three nucleotides that code for
different amino acids and that code is
the same and prokaryotes and new periods
that's why you can take a gene from a
human like for human insulin put it into
a bacterium and the bacterium can then
make and I protein identical to what the
human cells made because we all use that
same universal genetic code and we all
use the same 20 amino acids but some
prokaryotes have two additional amino
acids and those are Celino cysteine
and pyrrole I seen so some prokaryotes
will have Cellino cysteine and Pyrrha
lysine in some of their polypeptides
that eukaryotes are just sticking to the
other 20 amino acids if you're
interested in learning more about
couples transcription and translation in
prokaryotes you can see my video on that
topic you can also see my video on the
central dogma of molecular biology which
explains how information travels from
DNA through that RNA intermediate into a
polypeptide I've also got a nice video
on this universal genetic code
explaining how it's used and how mRNA is
read to build polypeptides and then I've
also got a video looking at the process
of transcription and how it differs in
prokaryotes and eukaryotes so feel free
to check out those videos and thanks for
watching biology professor I'll see you
next time